[Music]
too often we focus all of our attention
and our resources on developing the most
senior people in the organization if you
haven't invested some of those same
resources in developing a pipeline of
talent you may be disappointed when
people feel like they're not prepared to
assume this significant level of
responsibility
what we're trying to do is provide a way
for people to get that kind of training
or development a little earlier in their
careers so that they can polish those
skills and eventually grow into their
more senior leadership positions
participants
will gain an understanding of the key
concepts and fundamentals such as
finance accounting operations enabling
them to make better decisions become a
greater asset to the organization the
day they return
i picked eld because i want to
be an influential leader it's more about
the behavioral aspect of being a leader
inspiring your people coping with change
markets laws are changing too quickly to
not take that time to stop and reflect
and focus on you and what you can learn
and what you can do better
the break that came after the first
module
is a good opportunity to reflect
on what you are doing well and how you
want to do it how you want to move
forward
we help you take what you learn here and
really implement it in your organization
it's very very practical the knowledge
is easily implementable i know i always
have resources i can tap into it the
tools the the framework even though i
learn i may forget but i know how to
come back to find it
the amount of takeaways i've gotten from
the other people talking about the
things we've learned and has given us
just as much as the
sessions themselves the design thinking
the opportunity to come back the focus
on organisational behaviour and your own
leadership style as well stanford hasn't
disappointed on any of those
eld somebody said to me at a scale of 1
to 10 how would you rate it and my
answer was a 15. i returned to work with
so much more energy and positivity i
have a clearer plan in terms of what i
wanted to implement and where i wanted
to go i am excited because i think it's
going to make me a better leader i would
recommend this program to anyone who
wants to move their organization their
own position their future to the next
level
you just feel like hey i'm ready ready
to take on any challenge without any
fear it's transformation
[Music]
you